what's the biggest difference between
being you know in the Big Brother house
and now being here in the jury in this
place so many things are different yeah
it's way more relaxing you're not super
stressed out you don't have to think
game 24/7 and honestly for me it's the
perfect segue to go from game back to
reality because you have a little bit
more reality every day right but then
you can slowly stop thinking about game
but still be part of the game there are
still moments though the catch ourselves
being like you need to do this or you
know like the game is still in our
brains right it's slowly kind of fading
away but I think it'll take like a
little while still coming up as well so
we're still finding things about each
other game and it's giving us clarity
which is good because we have a big
decision to make
but it's interesting it's like what you
don't know you know you must still have
the competitive nature as part of your
relationship with each other you hang
out here and like have dinner or like
play out and there was like a sport
without feeling like oh my god kill that
person like yeah how's it feeling we
can't even play cards you're gonna find
the hill it's like the loser I think the
rest of our lives if we stay close it'll
be always kind of competitive people too
so it's hard to turn that it's cool
though because we've only known each
other I guess for like two and a half
months but I feel like I've known these
guys have been friends with them for
like years right we had so much time
condensed in the house together we got
and now we're getting to know each other
on a different level no so it's cool
it's cool it's like the Big Brother
effect right yeah yeah
are there game moves that happens that
you guys are still holding on to that
you're still salty about that come up a
lot these guys like I hated these guys
voted out Erica I think that was like a
major change for my game and we probably
all would have still been in the house
like laughing having a great time in
Final Four right now
so many variables I mean Kim and Erica
wanted a Leo and that wasn't good for my
game so even though thinking back to it
maybe it would have been an interesting
decision I could have changed I don't
think it would have been best for my
game in the end we'll never know never
know true we will never know I get I
said a lot too if I you know regret
keeping Johnny or pushing to keep Johnny
hmm and I would like to say there's no
regrets in this game there's way too
many variables to consider things can
change at any time and in that moment I
feel like live and I really felt like
that was our best decision even if it
turns out that it wasn't but in the
moment it felt right so when you left
obviously and we talked about this
before you blowing up you know calling
everybody out on I you know how was your
reaction to that being here in the house
together now oh I mean I expected Ali to
get that kind of reaction so I mean I
wasn't surprised to me but coming to the
house it was just like like we knew in
the game these the people who had like a
really easy connection with and that's
why we wanted to work together so you
know once you removed from the game it's
still that easy connection yeah and you
can yeah less people in the house too
and then a walk away in five minutes
everything oh yeah they're still yelling
in the jury house - I always all the
time like literally and then like five
minutes later I'm okay like it's the
thing yeah so what kind of jurors will
you guys become the you know the big
decision making a moment are you going
to be strategic is gonna be about
respecting gameplay or are you going to
let your emotions creep in like do you
want to be getting revenge on anybody
for anything what's it going to be like
for you open-minded I think I think
people who are left in the game they all
have their own individual game they've
played and I'm impressed by you each and
every one of them that's truly the case
so yeah I'm going into this with like
wanting to hear them state why they
think we should deserve the final prize
and if they convince me then they're
gonna get my vote right right yeah I'm
gonna take my own experiences which each
with each of them throughout the game
and definitely apply it to my final
decision and I'm gonna stay open-minded
as well and not make the decision until
I hear what they have to say and after
they answer the questions and I'll make
the decision on the spot right yeah
ditto like these guys for me
it's gonna be about keeping an open mind
the saltiness is slowly wearing away so
it's fine I think for me it's really
about asking those key questions and
just having people really own their game
for me it's just a matter of things have
happened live scheming manipulations but
if you can own it and tell me exactly
what you did and how you landed in that
final two then I'll respect that game
yeah you guys do sound very open-minded
about it but like deep in your heart
emotionally are you feeling like there's
anybody in there right now that you're
like this person does not get my vote
oh this preference is for sure yeah I
mean we couldn't possibly go on like
months of living with these people
without having some kind of preference
yeah I mean I'm rooting for I'd like to
say that I'm rooting against Dayla but I
do respect the game they've played but
like that's so many points was I at odds
with them in the game that is just like
this little part of me that wants to
still remain victorious over them just
like the competitive edge I don't know
um but I still think they played a great
game even them and will in Paris as well
so yeah we'll see yeah like I'm rooting
for dalla as well Derek or Kayla because
I feel like Ally and I we worked with
them relatively closely throughout the
last couple weeks of the game and I
think we saw a side to them that other
people maybe didn't see they're
definitely cons to giving them the vote
as well but I think for the most part
there's a lot of pros for me honestly
for me I flip-flopped so much and it's
funny cuz in the house I used to hate
flip floppers I get such a flip flopper
make up your mind flip swapping a lot
like when I first came in I was a
hundred percent go Kayla go no way to
Paris or will but now I'm like actually
you know what Derek is now rising and
like killing it so I'm like maybe Derek
but then I'm like oh maybe if I'm not
salty maybe Paris you did play a great
social manipulative game so I'm like
literally flip-flopping I have no idea
mm-hmm so speaking of David their their
teamwork carry them through obviously
they're a formidable team as far as
geomancer's go versus romances are they
the real deal or like what
yeah when you guys were so close right
you guys are closely inside you were so
closely with them so like what insight
can you give us on that relationship how
it works I think they definitely care
about each other because you definitely
connect I'm working with someone so
closely in the game however I don't know
if it's true love I mean it's I don't
know how it'll be perceived on TV being
with them living with them in the house
for me specifically I feel like it was
an attraction for sure but I don't know
if spending that much time around with
each other feelings developed as much as
one would have hoped I mean I think she
and I develop more feelings so when you
guys are discussing amongst each other
game play things that have happened kind
of working through maybe things as well
what are some of the most dunderheaded
moves like the dumbest things that have
happened in the house that you're just
like oh why did that happen why did you
do that yeah that was definitely one of
them yeah recently like post jury what
can guys think of hmm I think that when
they voted to evict me that was a real
[Laughter]
yeah I don't know I think it's hard to
say like what were really dumb moves
because I feel like everyone feels
justified like what might have been a
dumb move for me is probably like
somebody else feels justified in it so
it's really hard to say but well for
sure
Ryan nominating his best friend was so
stupid that was definitely a big one
yeah I was to say the most recent one
which I think we can mention yeah is the
will stepping off yeah in the veto yeah
for Derek's he should have stayed on
that wall
yes fought for it decided to make a move
because it's the end of the game it
can't float anymore you have to start
making moves and to me that was the
dumbest decision of all hmm he could
have sent Derek out that week
interesting so you guys think that you
know you guys are BFFs for life now you
guys have
through this whole thing you're gonna be
going through a jury together and
obviously you're gonna be carrying
certain saltiness I definitely think so
I mean Johnny and I live in live in
Vancouver together so sure I'll get to
see him often and come visit she says
and we'll be on this experience is so
unique that the people who went through
it with you even like passed Big Brother
alum like of course they've been through
it as well but like your season is so
unique that the people in your season I
think feel like you're gonna have a
forever bond with that's been like an
amazing experience but also a really
strange experience and one that like I
think only we can identify with so
absolutely I will always have that you
know yeah and also tell me how you like
saved breaking your foot for after what
a mess
doing some really impressive gymnastics
for these guys wall jumped off of it and
broke my foot so thanks so much yeah how
much smoke every time of this same six
weeks yeah I hope yeah just perfect